a lot of people that I've talked to that
have been in prison for a long time so
they've met a lot of their best friends
prisons all of you well I met a couple
of buddies I mean I'm say they've been
best friends but I thought I still keep
in touch with two of them yeah yeah okay
shout-out to chunk and John yeah a chunk
hit that truffle shuffle
he's wider than it is tall my buddies
he's five foot tall I'm 5 foot wide Wow
it's kind of like that girl on the Willy
Wonka the blue one yeah yeah oh hell
yeah but it isn't float he says it's
really short he's super thick full
Snickers king-size wave way bigger
[ __ ] yeah we're we're heavy metal wall
goddamn better believe it heavy metal is
the [ __ ] law and if you don't agree
with that then you just need to tune out
right now because we don't have time for
you let's take a five-second break so
these nerds can [ __ ] tune off a
moment of silence for the [ __ ] nerds
that think Metallica started at the
Black Album [ __ ] you [ __ ] load [ __ ]
reload and [ __ ] anything after that I
just found out that load is the album
cover is actually blood and semen I
always thought that the album cover was
Guy Fieri's forearms it's real blood and
semen whose blood and who semen have got
yeah that was the first time anybody has
been taken to flavortown
somebody called Billy Mays we're not
[Laughter]
back to the heavy metal so while Jake
was partying doing all those things and
doing all that [ __ ] I discovered heavy
metal listening to Metallica Slayer
yeah and all the things that you find
out early on and your journey through
non-commercial music me and Shane
went to a couple casualties shows yeah
one of the first shows I went to for
sure everyone who almost got beat up by
the lead singer was that Alex Alex yeah
yeah yeah yeah sounds about right yeah I
think I think he like Jorge almost
whupped it yeah who's not the lead
singer anymore actually but yeah I
remember them I don't know what we were
crazy back then we were just like we
would just wile out at the shows and
throw beers on stage and [ __ ] we were
like 1617 drinkin beers out there yep
hey getting [ __ ] up but that was a
good time so you know that whole thing
progresses and you just dive down the
the bottomless pit that is like the
legacy of heavy metal and it's just
something that always stuck with me and
I feel like once I discovered that I had
my thing and the thing that like I could
really own and as Jake was going through
his thing like I had my thing and you
know as he was suffering through
whatever he was suffering through and
going through whatever he was going
through with my parents like I just had
like my Slayer and Metallica albums and
it's it's very typical but sometimes
typical and cliche is what you need to
get through the really hard times yeah
and I always wanted him there and always
wish that like he could understand why
this music was good and like why there
was something there for you there's
something there for everybody like no
matter what emotion you're feeling no
matter what you're going through you can
throw on any one of those classic albums
and work through it and it just stuck
with me and so exhausted tune yeah for
some reason like when we started writing
and corresponding with each other while
he was in jail prison first yeah prison
he thanks for keeping bringing that up
like that not not the feds not the feds
though I'm a bottom of the barrel
[ __ ] criminal
he got a cockroach criminal he got a
music player and he was able to buy like
single mp3s
oh yeah and as I was writing him out
with like Tom to download [ __ ] so vague
download like some Nile download some
here's some Slayer here's like some
suicide silence here here's some no this
way whatever Slayer everybody should
listen to the Slayer die by the sword
and I don't give a [ __ ] like who's out
there if you got like some [ __ ] to talk
about it that first Suicide Silence
album is [ __ ] amazing I don't care
how true you think you are that [ __ ]
[ __ ] rips but anyway
Jake had that on his iPod or his prison
pod at one point so if anyway not my
person pocket and then I just kept
sending stuff to listen to and you know
I was going through my journey through
heavy metal playing shows doing my thing
and he was still just like locked up
doing his thing and you Photoshop some
sweet pictures like yeah Waffle House
yeah me Jake and Obama visited a Waffle
House at one point those they got okay
so funny about that was about my dad's
side of the family did not know was in
prison probably for four years I don't
know ever told granny well no she knew
oh she has you slipped up and told one
of our cousins so anyway my dad's side
of the family thought I was a hotel
manager in Tallahassee cutting trees I
was cutting trees in Fort Walton Beach
for a while you know I was doing some
holy [ __ ] all over they I guess they
were embarrassed to television or
something
they're like they're super [ __ ]
right-wing [ __ ] Christian prophecy
[ __ ] weirdos yeah and I guess that
doesn't go with that revelations yeah
but nobody nobody gives a [ __ ] about our
little family on my dad's side so that's
why we're here who gives a [ __ ] sorry
Florida yeah
so we started making plans for this
thing called MDF that was when we were
still working together yep it was
getting close to like a year him being
out you got to buy tickets for it like
probably like six to eight months out so
I was like [ __ ] it I'm going like full
[ __ ] MVP package spent like all the
money getting all the wristbands doing
all the [ __ ] getting everything lined up
and it's like hey we're doing this
because the one thing that you need to
get over like something that's bothering
you is like you need a goal to work
towards and I thought this was like a
really great thing for him to look
forward to and also a really great thing
for me to look forward to because I saw
him getting out as like the start of our
actual relationship as brothers and I
was just really grateful for that like
fourth chance that I got to like be
there and like hang out and like be cool
and be human together and I was so
pumped as told him and it gotten through
it and like we were talking about it
yeah the whole time leading up to it
like through your work release and
everything and I bring him doughnuts
while he was on work release and like we
drink out drink coffee before you'd have
to go to work and like I'd come up to a
clear water like jacked up off of like
[ __ ] for apple fritters and like
quadruple lattes from lighthouse Donuts
shout-out to light lighthouse donors oh
we actually where was the work release
well we never got quads
we ordered quads one day lattes and the
guy goes we don't do that quadruple
latte yeah yeah and we got through it
and we made it to the trip yeah oh that
was amazing just just kind of opened my
eyes to that there's more to life in
Pinellas County yeah yeah although like
the Pinellas County is a great place
this part of Florida is really great is
it's really great if you're like 60 and
coming down and you're not an ex-con
[ __ ] scumbag piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]